the answer is red in addition to the two
parameters being passed between
parentheses which of course get bound to
the input parameters 1 & 2 I'm now
passing a third parameter by calling
that function on the right side of a dot
access for property look up the value
that appears on the left of that dot
will automatically be given the name
this inside of that function invocation
this behavior is useful if we plan on
doing much object oriented programming
since there will usually be a relevant
focal object for any given method call
and that object generally appears to the
left of the dot when the method gets
called